next Neil deGrasse Tyson talks about the
controversy over reclassifying the
former planet Pluto as a comet
New York's American Museum of Natural
History where this talk was held was the
first public institution to adopt this
position this program is about an hour
35 minutes just kidding c-span just
testing the microphone got a little more
volume on that if I may thank you
testing more more more more testing
there we go
Pluto it was an ugly scene January 22nd
2001 that was the night actually that
was the morning I woke up came to my
office there were some uncountable
number of voicemail messages on my
telephone that morning that morning the
phone was ringing why the New York Times
had a page one story proclaiming Pluto
not a planet
only in New York where'd that come from
this is January 22nd 2001 what happened
just two days before then tell me
inauguration of George W okay you'd
think the whole page one would be filled
with stories on the transition to power
why not they were still counting dimpled
Chad's in Florida you think that should
be enough content to fill the page I
have a mock-up of that page right here
okay so here it is and rightfully so
right at the top I'll read it to you on
the first day Bush settles into a
refitted Oval Office so there he goes
it's right there this is actually the
second news day of the inauguration but
there's other items here obviously 37
new Cardinals selected by the Pope okay
it's big news a local Cardinal was a
local guy was was was elevated here's on
Iraq rebuilt weapons factories US
officials say it's fun to see new
stories after you know better you know
just kind of it's just kind of there it
is you know you got it I what else we
got here California they have these
rolling brownouts at the time
worried about their power supply new
plants in California racing for time
they had to get him ready for four for
the summer okay fine
and then there it goes Pluto not a
planet
only in New York as she walked past the
display of photos of planets at the Rose
Center for Earth and space
Pamela Curtis of Atlanta scrunched her
brow perplexed there didn't seem to be
enough planets
she started counting on her fingers
trying to remember the mnemonic her son
had learned in school years ago my very
educated mother just served us nine
pizzas then she went along the list
Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn
Uranus Neptune quote I had to go through
the whole thing to figure out what was
missing she said Pluto Pluto wasn't
there now I know my mother just served
us nine nine nothing's the next line
quietly and apparently uniquely among
major scientific institutions the
American Museum of Natural History
cast Pluto out of the pantheon of
planets when it opened the Rose Center
for Earth and space
so with all I come from first of all we
got accused of just trying to drum up
attendance just making controversy just
for the hell of it
all right oh yeah let's just make up a
cosmic controversy whether or not it's
true just to get people in the front
door fact is that exhibit had been that
way for a year we didn't open in 2001 we
opened in 2000 February okay it had been
that way for a year so the New York
Times came late in this one so let's
back up let's just back out it's the
1990s the museum had just finished its
new dinosaur halls the entire fourth
floor of this museum filled with
dinosaurs attendance was on the rise yet
attendance at the Hayden Planetarium was
dropping simultaneously with the rise in
attendance at the dinosaur halls
meanwhile we had Rovers on Mars and and
the space shuttle and Hubble was up
there was no reason for attendance to
visit the universe to drop the
institution was deeply concerned said we
got to do something about it alright
that's when I came in mid-1990s he built
the staff we looked at the problem
looked at the state of our understanding
of the universe started designing
exhibits the exhibit designer Ralph
Appelbaum and associates perhaps best
known for the Holocaust Museum in
Washington DC work closely with him and
architects Jim pulchik and partners so
there we are
laying out the lesson plan and we notice
we notice something what did we notice
there are objects being discovered in
the outer solar system beyond Neptune
adding to our inventory of what's out
there what are these objects look like
they're kind of small who knows kind of
small what else about them they're kind
of I see Pluto's kind of ice
what kind of war [ __ ] well their orbits
are a little weird like Pluto's orbit
you may know Pluto's orbit is is
strongly elliptical by far the most
elliptical II orbiting planet there is
called it a planet there for the moment
and so it crosses the orbit of Neptune
no other planet does that to any other
planet so that's odd not only that if
you look at the plane in which planets
orbit Pluto is tipped out of that plane
by 17 degrees everybody else Mercury's
tipped a little too but not as much as
Pluto everybody else is kind of right
there a couple of degrees up or down
within the plane what we call the plane
of the solar system so as these objects
start getting discovered we say to
ourselves what are they what do they
represent what do they mean this is in
the mid 1990s we know we want to rebuild
the facility so we want to make we're
looking at trend lines in what science
is doing and then those trend lines we
say something's going on out there let's
take a closer look we take a closer look
and we find out that what is being
discovered is a Zone in the solar system
predicted to be there at mid-century a
solar system theorist named Gerard
Kuiper hypothesized that beyond the
orbit of the farthest most large planet
if there's not another large planet out
there then they'd be the leftovers from
the formation of the solar system that
never got gravitationally vacuumed up to
become part of that large planet if
there's no large planet it would just
still be there so we said maybe there's
a reservoir of icy bodies out there we
went 40 45 years before such an object
was discovered we needed the biggest
telescopes in the world biggest optical
telescopes right now there in Hawaii the
Keck telescope was brought to bear on
this problem
we discovered we we've got people who I
wasn't a peeps colleagues discovered the
Kuiper belt discovered it so we said to
ourselves maybe Pluto is not the ninth
out of nine planets maybe Pluto is a
member of a new class of object
predicted to be there at mid-century so
let us create a display that captures
this fact most museums all museums that
present the planets do it in a way that
you first learned it in elementary
school there's a panel there's a wall
and they're panels so the first one is
mercury and it gives you the data on
mercury how big it is what's made of its
orbital period then you go to Venus and
then Earth and then either there it is
mercury through Pluto it is an
enumeration of objects sitting there for
you to memorize and we saw an
educational and scientific opportunity
to rethink how we're going to deliver
the solar system to you we said to
ourselves that's not how we're going to
do it
there's too much else to learn to
understand to to relate to about the
solar system rather than thinking of it
as an enumeration of objects so instead
what we did was create a new sort of
family photo of the solar system
organizing objects by similar properties
we took Pluto and said Pluto you look
more much more like these other objects
than you or these other objects look
like anybody else in the solar system
you're going to be a new group for us
there's the Kuiper belt of icy bodies
there it is with Pluto a prominent
member among them next we had the gas
giants Jupiter Saturn Uranus and Neptune
they're big they're low-density they
have rings they have huge moon systems
that's a group they have more in common
with each other than any one of them has
with anything else that's kind of what
you want for a classification scheme
that's how classification schemes work
at their best we had this the rocky
planets Mercury Venus Earth and Mars
were all small we're all dense royal
rocking similar density that was a group
the asteroid belt separating the rocky
planets from the gas giants and last out
there the Oort cloud a cloud call it a
cloud it is a zone of comets that
completely surrounds the solar system
hence the word cloud as distinct from
belt which is slightly flattened in the
plane the Oort cloud is a reservoir of
comets that extends halfway to the
nearest stars so these are communities
of objects that's how we present to the
solar system at no time did we count
planets fact we devalued the very
meaning of the word planet because it
wasn't very useful to us if I say to you
today I just discovered a planet
orbiting another star you can have to
play 20 questions with me you're gonna
say was it big as as small as it gasps
just doesn't have rings doesn't it and
by the time we're done you've asked me
20 questions why because the word planet
was not useful to you it was no longer a
discriminating term if you have
bookshelves I can say one of five things
and you'll know exactly what I'm talking
about I said bring me the book bring me
the encyclopedia bring me the dictionary
bring me the paperback bring me the
pamphlet bring me the DVD okay or the
what else bring me the you know the
files I don't say bring me the wood-pulp
you know which would then apply to
everything there we have words that
distinguish one object from another
which creates great utility in the act
of communicating and delivering
information so what we wanted but we're
not audacious enough to create was a new
lexicon to account for what we now know
about the objects in the solar
that's what we did so when the New York
Times headline said Pluto not a planet
only in New York it's not actually true
and in all fairness to the author of
that article
Kenneth Chang upstart science writer
we're friends actually it all fairness
to him he didn't write that title as you
know these media places they have the
title people they come in they browse
what you sketch it and then they put
give it a title as inflammatory as
possible and so he knows that nowhere
did we say they're now only eight
planets but I'll tell you as the media
storm unfolded they kept coming sticking
microphones in my face saying so how
many planets are there they kept trying
to get me to say oh they're only eight
planets and make death the soundbite but
it never came out of my mouth not ever
okay because that's not what we did if
you want to go there you got to watch
out because yes Pluto's small but
consider this
Jupiter is more bigger compared with
earth than earth is compared with Pluto
so if we were like Jupiter Ian's alright
no such word actually Jovian if we were
Jovians and we were asked how many
planets are there in the solar system
you know what we would say for Jupiter
Saturn Uranus and Neptune and the rest
is just debris all right so so Earth is
smaller than Jupiter's red spot okay the
storm it's a storm on it's on it weather
system been going for 300 years at least
earth fits nicely right inside the red
spot Jupiter was slammed by a comet back
in 1994 comet shoemaker-levy 9 this is a
comet that used to be one piece and
during one of the flybys of Jupiter
Jupiter's tidal forces of gravity broke
it into multiple segments two dozen
segments each piece fell in separately
as Jupiter rotated and it had like pock
marks one right after another the pock
marks would breaketh bigger than earth
okay so it's not about counting planets
here it was never about counting planets
so but I was so angry angered by this
with all these microphones going in my
face I want it I wanted to have a reply
that would just send them off happy so
here's what I wanted to say say so doc
you tension are there only eight planets
in the solar system I want to say yeah
Pluto wasn't bigger to me Pluto isn't
big enough to make it in New York so I
wanted to say we kicked it out Manhattan
was just too big for need for it for
Pluto I wanted to say that just to give
him something that you want so my life
was completely upended that day because
I was fielding inquiries from the public
my boss called me okay my boy who's my
boss my bought you didn't ask but I'm
gonna tell you I boss is the Provost of
this August institution the Provost is
the chief academic officer of any place
of academic study all universities have
Provost's if they don't have a provost
nobody's learning anything they're let's
just keep that in mind that is the head
of the academic organization of an
institution the Provost calls me up that
day I was still relatively new I only
been hired a few years earlier okay kind
of young you know what did he say to me
he said uh Neil he's trying to protect
the institution's reputation and here we
are scattered all over page one said
what did you do said did you decide this
by yourself I said no no I got we got
people we got people we it was unanimous
in fact there's a committee we got
people I got people but not only that
we're not stupid okay 1999 we saw the
writing on the wall we said let's brand
locally one of us is a sort of a solar
system expert and that's Steve Sodor
when a colleague of
my friend and colleague so he would have
sort of deeper insight into the solar
system upfront than the rest of us would
not that we couldn't acquire some
insight but we said let's do this
professionally in full in full-blown
style so we invited in the world's
experts on this subject and conducted a
panel pluto panel took place 10 years
ago March in the main auditorium it was
to debate what was going on with Pluto
and it on that panel I had one of the co
discoverers of the first Kuiper belt
object ok so here's somebody who's
looking in the outer solar system
I got someone who's head of of the
commission of the of the committee's
that worry about nomenclature in
astronomy I got the biographer of the
discoverer of Pluto you know where he's
going to land on that issue ok I got I
got all the right people and we sat back
and listened
listen to the strength of arguments
listen to the scientific listen to the
data being brought forth on those
arguments and we didn't even have we
didn't even have to caucus at the end of
this it was clear that Pluto's days as
the ninth planet were numbered no pun
intended so one day well we still have
the tapes for that debate one day we'll
figure out a way to like put it online
and you can all relive the history with
us we were count there's a lot of that
dialogue recounted in in the Pluto files
I should like put a copy of the book
right here how you supposed to do that
so the camera always has to look at the
book that's how that works
learn that from Andy Rooney right there
put it right there yeah I just stand
next to it like that save now you got by
the way the American Museum of Natural
History is my host home institution and
I made an arrangement and agreement with
the upper-level administration that
whatever of these however many books you
buy tonight all of the royalties that
would go to me are going back to the
museum so it's all being folded back
into the programs here so you can buy
with abandon at the at the checkout line
I won't gain from it so let's back up in
time 1930
that's when Pluto was discovered by
Clyde Tombaugh homegrown farm boy from
the Midwest Clyde Tombaugh he actually
took on the search for Planet X launched
by Percival Lowell this Lowell of the
New England Lowell's moneyed Tweedy
couldn't find a picture of him without a
tweed jacket on
he found a mountain in Arizona with his
very low humidity humidity is bad for
observations from a telescope built an
observatory called it the Lowell
Observatory and launched the search for
Planet X Planet X was this fabled
perturb er of Neptune the orbit of
Neptune the then farthest most planet
was not following what you'd expect it
to do from Newton's laws of gravity so
you're left with two choices either
Newton's laws of gravity fail at this
distance from the Sun but we were not
quick to give it up because Newton's
laws were working they were working for
centuries so what's what's the
alternative maybe there's an onion to be
discovered other object out there whose
gravity was influencing that tomb
yet you hadn't reckoned it in your
equations yet meanwhile Newton's laws
would all just still be fine
thus was born planet x Percival Lowell
wanted to find Planet X you do the
arithmetic it's more than arithmetic you
do the math to find out you say if
neptune is doing this and it should be
doing that then the object should be
there so train your telescopes in that
direction and look for it they looked
over they couldn't find couldn't find
planet a so I should be there look there
couldn't find it all right what's going
on here well Clyde Tombaugh comes in a
little later and says let's do a
systematic survey of the night sky
rather than this targeted searches let's
just look at everything and he looks at
everything Annie discovers Pluto the
first planet discovered by an American
so Americans have a certain investment
in this object not only that if you look
at the sizes given for Pluto right when
it was discovered it was assumed that it
was planet acts first of all second if
it was planted X we would need a mass
and a gravity commensurate with that of
Neptune so the earliest estimates for
Pluto size was an object the size of
Neptune over the years as measurements
got more and more refined our best
estimates for the size of Pluto got
littler and littler and littler and
littler the size of Pluto didn't settle
out until the 1970s and when it did
there are seven moons in the solar
system bigger than Pluto including
Earth's moon fully half the Pluto lovers
I've ever told that to did not know that
fact that's because the Pluto Lobby does
not lead with that information they hold
that back you got to like dig it out of
them oh the moon is bigger okay and so
is Ganymede and Titan and you just go on
down the list but like I said I want to
make a thing about size because we would
that one to Jupiter so up just but still
Pluto lovers many did not know that
who here did not know that that their
seven moons t raise your hand did not
know they never told they never told you
they never told you never told you I'm
telling you 19:30 Pluto's discovered by
the way the size of Pluto was dropping
precipitously according to our best
estimates there's a tongue-in-cheek
paper written in the late 1970s and it
just looked at the size of Pluto and
made a plot the grass the size of Pluto
according to the year that an estimate
was made for it and the decides was just
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and then they extrapolated into the
future and so the title of the article
was the pending disappearance of Pluto
and it goes through the x-axis in 1984
you know so they were worried that Pluto
would disappear completely so I've got
the abstract and the actual published
plot of the paper in the Pluto files so
it's fun to read that because if the
author's obviously knew CUDA was not
going to disappear but it's just fun to
watch this trend line
it sort of pokes fun at the process of
or has has fun with the process of what
it took to get the size of Pluto
correctly it's so far and so little and
so did so here here we are I'm getting
mail after that article appeared I
started getting hate mail from like
third graders pissed off third graders
like I upset their worldview like a
third grader has a worldview you know
I'm able to since when does that happen
your third grader like so why did why do
I do it and I didn't get this reaction
from Europeans Europeans like prime the
motive okay
pass the wine you know and it has had
other issues and Europe they're cool
American people just went ate and I
trying to understand that and I said
well how do I come to understand this
what's going on
then you look back you comb the history
books and you discover that in 1930 Walt
Disney first sketches a dog a dog that
would get the name of Pluto Pluto the
dog the Disney dog and Pluto the cosmic
object have the same tenure in the
hearts and minds of Americans and
American didn't name the cosmic object
we discovered it we didn't name it we
couldn't have named it it turns out no
way an American could have named that
object Pluto it was named by an 11-year
old girl in Cambridge England a very
connected 11 year old girl her father
was like head of the Cambridge library
who was buddies with the astronomer
royal and so she just learned with Roman
mythology in her class and heard about
this new discovery been made all the
world news in America and thought that
Pluto is like the god of the underworld
it's sort of dark and far and you don't
want to go there and said wouldn't Pluto
be a good name for it and so it worked
its way up the ranks and it's stuck
and thus the announcement came an
American could not have named it Pluto
first would not that educated when we're
11 years old
ok yes let me reflect on my Roman
mythology I just learned in class today
no well maybe we were back then I don't
know but there's a stronger reason why I
would have never come out of our brains
because in the 1920s right on up through
the early 30s there was a heavily
advertised widely marketed mineral
laxative called Pluto water
with the slogan when nature won't Pluto
will so when it cosmic objects is
discovered you just not think in the
word Pluto I'm sorry it's not happening
it's just not
Venetia Burney that's the name of the
little girl she's like 80 something now
87 still alive by the way see there's an
interview with her online we give the
link in the book there's an interview
with you can hear talk about how she
named named Pluto so we made it sound
okay uh so I've come to the conclusion
the following conclusion about what age
do you first learn about the planets
you're like in first second or third
grade something like that right about
right what grade are you in third grade
have you did you learn about the planets
this year or last year mostly this year
so third grade that's that's the grade
okay now when you're a kid when you're a
normal app when you're an average kid
that's the age you're watching cartoons
and like I said in America we haven't
learned our Roman mythology yet so when
you first learn the planet and they
start giving you because they're only
teaching it as an enumeration of objects
and here they go ready mercury that's
just a name it doesn't mean wing and
messenger from ancient Rome it's just a
word Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter
Saturn years M Bruno oh that's the doll
Omega energy and right at that moment
you get genetically in it's it's it's
it's painted into your brain cells this
connection and it stays with you your
whole life
admit it unless you have another
accounting for this I have no other
accounting for why Americans cared so
much and I have evidence from adults
that I will read to you that supports
this contention by the way I work here
at the Museum I do
astrophysics but I share the corridors
with colleagues of mine who are
zoologists people who study the rest of
the animal kingdom okay including humans
we have like like anthropologists who
study humans so everything that walks
slithers moves on this earth we got
somebody who's an expert in it okay so I
have a certain osmotic sensitivity to
the animal kingdom for working here
which led me to question this has
nothing to do with anything but just you
just hang with me for a minute
I'm there trying to solve this problem
and I say how is it that Pluto is
Mickey's dog yet Mickey is not Pluto's
Mouse this disturbed me this uh there's
like so there's some there's some like
disturbance in the space-time continuum
of the mammalian order of things that's
not right I would not have otherwise
been distracted by this except that I
work here I had to get to the bottom I
called up Disney I said what what so
what's going on here
I got the answer and if you know the
answer I got the answer you ready I'm
telling you in the Disney pantheon of
cartoon characters not the ones that
they bought later like like Winnie the
Pooh they just bought Winnie the Pooh
they didn't invent when I'm taller the
ones that they sketched out of their own
their own cartoon labs in that Pantheon
if you're an animal who wears clothes
you can own other animals who do not
that's it
simple as that so so Mickey's got the
gloves the paint that sure whatever he
wears I don't know what they called but
he's wearing clothes okay
Pluto's butt-naked little walks on all
fours Pluto doesn't speak Pluto lives in
a doghouse
goofy walks bipedally wears clothes pays
rent in a house that's how that works I
know you were burning to know that but I
can't keep that to myself so here we are
my emails coming in fielding enquiries
I'm trying to answer to my boss he
doesn't believe me
I say look I had a committee it was a
consent he doesn't need him believe me
he went callin around other people he
called the Provost because Provost
talked to pros at Princeton who happened
to be an astrophysicist a world famous
astrophysicist now I spent 13 years at
Princeton before I came here so they all
know me down there they know who what I
do how I do it they called called him up
and said you know what do you make of
this thing that our guy
Ison judge did and he said Provost of
Princeton said whatever Tyson did that's
that's correct just wanna come this
that's it just chill out let it be what
that is that'll turn out to be correct
and so I'm happy to announce that six
years later that would have been now
five years later we were the first
institution to bring this story public
in any percolating in the scientific
lounges up until up until then we were
just the first to make a public stink
about it well actually we didn't make
the stink the times made the stink so
what's happening over that time more
Kuiper belt objects are being discovered
two of them larger than Pluto
I see bodies in the outer solar system
if you're not going to call
planets and they're bigger than Pluto
that pools Pluto down into whatever you
going to call them doesn't it you can't
have Pluto sittin up above you and
you're bigger than Pluto
so this threw the whole planet
definition into question why was this
such controversy anyway you ever seen
scientists fighting like this by the way
the hate mail that I got was not just
from elementary school children I got
some from colleagues too all right
everybody was choosing up sides
everybody everybody so over those years
the Kuiper belt is fleshing out giving
more ammo to those who want to think of
the Kuiper belt as its own entity so
here we are the professional
international community of
astrophysicists say we've got to address
this problem we've got to now define
planet you might be thinking wasn't the
word defined before this no the word
planet had not been unambiguously
defined since ancient Greece in ancient
Greece they looked up at the night sky
they saw some objects wandered against
the background sky and others stayed put
what's the Greek word for Wanderers
planet s the Wanderers that's where we
get the word planet it's derived from
the Greek there were seven Wanderers
Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter Saturn the
Sun and the moon unambiguous planets
everybody agreed those wander against
the background sky by the way the fact
that the word wander was used tells you
no one really understood what they were
doing if you knew what they were doing
in while you wouldn't say they were
wandering right so it's a statement of
our scientific ignorance of the day so
these are the seven wonders that names
for our seven days of the week are
traceable to those seven wonders through
Roman and Norse mythology so Saturday is
for what Saturn who didn't know that
said Saturn comes from Saturday didn't
know right then they cool says about
Sunday what
the Sun thank you seaweed it would this
is an easy game we're playing here okay
okay let's let has one a little harder
moon day how about that what you got
that one has your chance to redeem
yourself the moon yeah moon moon day is
that so you trick they're all traceable
the seven planets all right
and there's everyone was happy with that
until Copernicus comes along 15:43
it's at the Year mid-1500s he says to
himself wait a minute
he's Nicolai Copernicus polish
astronomer mathematician wait a minute
maybe Earth is not what's in the center
of all this motion he was flowing the
geocentric worldview into question he
said maybe the Sun is in the middle and
these other objects go around the Sun
including earth and maybe the moon goes
around Earth so at that moment the
planet count changed we lost the Sun in
the moon 7 minus 2 is 5 and we gained
what Earth so went down to 5 up 1 to 6
planet count changed but no one defined
planet at that point it was just kind of
it's got remain if it goes around the
Sun let's just kind of agree that it's a
planet let's just agree but it was no
one sat down and wrote the formal
definition for it and but it was okay
because nothing threw it into question
until 1801 1801 January 1st telescopes
are getting bigger and better over all
these decades from Galileo now the 400th
anniversary of his telescope being used
to look at the night sky and it's
celebration of that we are in the
International Year of astronomy by the
way if you didn't know it there's 10
days in April where it is the goal
whether or not we achieve it to get all
six and a half billion people in the
world to at least once look through a
telescope that's the International Year
of astronomy this
that's gonna be hard okay gonna be work
you know Pleakley New York you put your
telescope on the street hey you want to
look through this
you're like people we was i before I
interrupted myself was that talking
about 1801 somebody's paying attention
right here she's paying attention right
here in the front row 1801 1801 a new
planet is discovered orbiting between
Mars and Jupiter there's a big gap that
we've always known that's the gap
between the rocky small planets and the
gas giants there's a gap people were
looking hard in that gap they found a
new planet and they named it planet
Ceres ever heard of planet Ceres cer es
rage Han if you've never heard of planet
Ceres never heard of it big news back in
1801 where we in ok named for the Roman
goddess of sort of grain and farming and
harvest that's in fact the root word to
today the word we use is cereal cereal
comes from Ceres okay an element
discovered on the periodic chart of
elements shortly after that object got
named was named after that object okay
that's cerium cer II um so you read
something like that ends an I um I get
that right so everyone was excited they
looked harder again they found another
planet and then another and then another
and then another I've got books from the
early 1800 that list the planet counted
like thirteen planets what's going on
this is getting out of hand
dozens of them started showing up the
scraping bottom four names now you need
a Roman god or goddess and need a symbol
and what's going on it paused took a
step back and said well how big are
these object they're small small in any
object they never discovered how do they
orbit well they kind of all orbit to get
they're in this sort of belt around the
Sun realized they weren't discovering
new planets they discovered a new swath
of real estate in the solar system that
today we call the asteroid belt and
overnight the planet count dropped from
whatever it was in the high 20s whatever
was the last one where people said this
is ridiculous something else is
happening here and went back down to
just Mercury Venus Earth Mars by then
Jupiter Saturn and Uranus all right yeah
Uranus Neptune hadn't been discovered
yet okay so we have I heard that story
before right we could Ceres was just the
first of a new class of object wasn't it
so look the woman we brought in who was
the co-discoverer of the first Kuiper
belt object she actually discovered the
second Kuiper belt object didn't she
what was the first Budo discovered by
clyde tombaugh 1930 now this thing about
planet names by the way oh just I should
tell you just because we're here you
know you're here why not planets are
named after Roman gods because you
hadn't figured that out as an homage to
Roman mythology that so graces our night
sky but how about the Greek mythology
want to sort of homage to them too so in
fact the moons of planets are named for
the assorted Greek characters in the
life of the Greek god who's the
counterpart to the Roman god after whom
the planet is named got that who didn't
get that be honest there you go one
honest person rescue all lying all right
here you go here's an example Jupiter
one of Jupiter's moons is Ganymede
Ganymede was the manservant of
Zeus and Zeus is the Greek counterpart
to Jupiter because these gods sort of
correspond with each other like if you
have the lightning bolt they both had a
lightning bolt but one was more powerful
they all they have correspondence with
each other so planet moons are named
after Greek characters no shortage of
characters to draw upon because these
mythological character gods they all had
very complicated social lives so there's
no shortage William Herschel an English
astronomer it was actually the first
person to ever discover a planet
he discovered Uranus actually quite by
by accident discovered it as the next
planet after Saturn now he does know
whatever discovered a planet or there's
no rules and regulations about what to
do what to do in fact he was in denial
of this fact you leave the writings and
the writings of others he says about the
people had discovered comets before no
one ever discovered a planet he says
this is a curious comet it refuses to
show a tail what don't we to make of
this comet it's a planet ok that's what
he discovered now like any good
scientist time to name the thing
what do you name it after you name it
after your thunder that's if you're a
good scientist this is what you do
keep your funders happy so they keep
writing your check so he names it after
King George so for a while there the
sequence of planets with Mercury Venus
Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn and George
okay
now I don't know about you but there's
something wrong with that I can't I
can't now the Brits are powerful
economically militaristically powerful
politically powerful you can't just say
we're not going to call it George
when they discovered the object you got
you need some quid quo pro there so what
ultimately happened was clearer heads
prevailed a Roman god was introduced as
the name of the object but you had to
keep the British happy somehow so the
lone exception among all the planets is
that the moons of Uranus are not named
after Greek characters and named after
Shakespearean character fictional
Shakespearean character as an homage to
the Brits for having discovered the
first planet so Uranus has a puck Oberon
titania Portia not the car Portia I'm
sorry
P ort I a Miranda my daughter's name is
Miranda and I'd known Miranda because
I'd known the moon and I'm far less
literate than my wife is but I knew I
liked the name Miranda so I said to her
you know I like Miranda what do you
think of that if we ever have a girl she
said Oh Miranda you mean the heroine is
Shakespeare's The Tempest I said uh yeah
yeah that's exactly yeah yeah so that's
how we name things so when Pluto's moon
was discovered 1978 Pluto has a moon you
got to find a Greek character in the
life of Hades which is the Greek
counterpart to Pluto and so is named
after Sharon who is the ferry boat
driver that carried your soul you're
dead unfortunate soul across the river
into Hades okay that's how that played
out in case you were wondering so let's
fast forward to 2006 international
community of astrophysicist votes they
set up a naming Capanna because the
planet had not been named since ancient
Greece I told you that that's why they
were these fights that's why people
chose up sides normally if something is
defined you could argue about the
definite
but you're not choosing up sides the
argument is very different once you have
a clean definition we didn't even have a
clean definition so there was a planet
definition committee set up and they
said okay and I looked at who was on the
committee they're like Pluto lovers on
that committee all right I saw that so
they came out with a new definition of a
planet and here it comes ready a planet
is an object that orbits the Sun Pluto
gets a check for that one yes and is
round okay that's kind of like almost
everybody isn't it that proposal got
voted down by the attending members of
that symposium they said you got to do
better than this
you got unit we need it's got to be more
discriminatory than that the thinking
was is that by the way if you're a rock
you're not so just a rock you have
whatever shape you have you're not round
reason why you're not round is your own
gravity isn't strong enough to make you
round if you are big there is a size
beyond which your own gravity overcomes
the structural integrity of the very
molecules that shape you and it puts you
into a nice round shape earth is round
for that very reason you might say no
it's not round we have mountains and
valleys and and deep parts and high
parts you might say excuse me pause what
is the highest point above our surface
that you know what is it
Mount Everest how high up is it in miles
given many miles five miles up what is
the deepest part of Earth's crust
Marianas Trench how deep is that six
miles down so from the deepest part of
Earth's crust to the highest part of
Earth's crust is 11 miles that's less
than the length of man
yet we're 8,000 miles in diameter if I
Shrunk earth down to the size of a cue
ball would be the smoothest cue ball
ever manufactured if you had a finger
and you reached out and rubbed it across
the surface of the earth you were some
cosmic giant you would not distinguish
what was Mountain Valley ocean or land
because all of that fluctuation would
happen within the thickness of the
imprint of your fingerprint do you know
that the globe the school globe you have
in the classroom you got one of these
Globes you ever run your fingers over it
and you feel where the mountain ranges
are the Himalayan mountains and the
Rockies they're lying to you okay they
are lying you would not feel that at all
the geologists have been lying to us
forever
it's the geologists fault it's greatly
exaggerated bumps on the globe in fact
the very extent of our atmosphere the
our atmosphere on that globe would be
thinner than the shellac on that globe
that's the atmosphere we think is a
great extent because we're the little
creatures at the bottom of it but
compared to the earth if nothing now on
you know why I went there but I had to
get that or like off my chest there
nothing to do with Pluto where was I
who's the one paying attention where was
I Braun thank you thank you
so are you round so that would mean
planet that category would have things
as small as Pluto and as large as
Jupiter Pluto being mostly ice by volume
Jupiter being mostly gas by volume they
would be in the same category that
disturbed me as an educator and as a
scientist the vote was taken that was it
was turned down they voted it they said
no they proposed a new plan they said
all right round is good we like that but
add two more criteria are you the
principal object in orbit around the Sun
so is Pluto gets a check there it's got
a moon Pluto's got a moon but it's the
principal object who gets a second check
according to the round criterion moons
would have been planets too so we would
have gone from nine planets to like 50
planets all right
had it only been the first criterion so
second are you the principal object yes
Pluto has two checks third do you
dominate your orbital zone is your
orbital zone cleared of debris no that's
right not with Pluto is not that's the
whole point we discovered the Kuiper
belt littering the orbital zone of Pluto
Pluto and if it was a game show we'll
just go ant rotate Pluto off the stage
it is no longer planet there's a new
word for it called a dwarf planet Pluto
gets quote demoted to dwarf planet
status Ceres which is round the only
asteroid that's round gets elevated to
dwarf planet before it's just an
asteroid it's a dwarf planet because
it's round it's the principal object in
orbit around the Sun has not cleared its
own it's in the asteroid belt there you
have it okay so many people got oh by
the way that those criteria were voted
90 percent to 10 percent in favor and
then it was set into law into into
suggested practice by the International
Astronomical Union it's not a labor
union it's just a society the
International Society of astrophysicists
and so another media frenzy unfolded
after that because we sort of started it
but they finished it and with sentiment
that greatly resonated with what our
concerns were that you needed to do
something with Pluto poodle lovers were
upset by this just demotion and I
thought well is it really a demotion
maybe dwarf plant is just a kind of
planet if you
a compact car are you thinking I'm not
really driving a car you're still
driving a car it's just a compact car so
maybe Pluto is still a planet it's just
a dwarf planet but that didn't fly with
the Pluto lovers out there so this 10%
are actually quite vocal they issued a
petition circulated internationally and
they are likely to show up at these
conferences persistently to get Pluto
reinstated as a planet meanwhile like I
said here we don't we're not even going
there I'm not counting planets I don't
care how many there are
doesn't matter and part of what unfolded
in night in 2006 was this part of the
frenzy was you knew the science hit
culture because humorists got a hold of
the material there were cartoons my
favorite of which was by a cartoonist
named Chaz almond he drew this orb this
Pluto orb sad face on the street corner
holding out a beggar's Cup I know and a
sign that's a victim of downsides the
cuter the kids wrote in this one just
got to show you this and we'll almost
done we'll go to cue a real quick this
was the very first letter that came to
my office on page 111 can't see it here
but it's written by a seven-year-old kid
how old are you by the way eight and a
half that's right don't let that half go
away and that half I'm waiting for
someone who's like 80 to say I'm 80 and
a half you know I'm just waiting for
that you reach the age nobody says that
nobody says that but school when you're
when you're like when you're young dear
Natural History Museum
you are missing planet Pluto please make
a model of it this is what it looks like
it is a planet
love will gamma turn the other page and
you drew a picture of Pluto
in crayon in case I do so what's funny
about this letter is that he just
assumed it was just kind of an oversight
we just like happen to leave it at wood
oops we forgot
thanks well like it's like an exhibit
typo you know so this was back in 2000
this actually predated
the New York Times article so we'll
gamma noticed it before the New York
Times gained just make that clear um so
what happens is six years later the 7
year olds the 8 year old the 9 year olds
they're now in high school with other
sort of hormonal priorities occupying
their attention the next generation of
3rd graders at the time the actual vote
was taken were already born into an
understanding of this controversy so the
letters I got from elementary school
kids after 2006 are much more consoling
and much more understanding I lead with
one here dear dr. Neil Tyson deGrasse at
first remember all those kids that sent
you bad letters well I want to apologize
for all the things we were wrong about
we're sorry about giving you mean
letters saying we love Pluto but not you
I'm very sorry it'll be ok Taylor age 7
this letter came in spring 2008 so just
like set 8 months ago
managed to make the printing deadline
and I got another letter here another
one that just the kids finally got it
that we knew we were doing something
right as educators another letter
towards the end
dear mr. Neil deGrasse Tyson I know how
you feel we feel the same about Pluto
not being a planet I am too but would we
just have to get over it that's science
we like to learn about science because
science will make you smart
love Siddiq age 8 so there was
definitely a shift I know it's only two
letters but trust me the statistics bear
this out twice called the Pluto files I
got files on this they the kids finally
understood that there's more going on in
the solar system than just an
enumeration of planets and with the
enumeration of planets that was a good
idea when there's nothing else to talk
about and all they were were just dots
of light on the night sky sure call them
planets but we know too much about them
now to believe that they're memorized
enumeration has anything to do with
science at all and so while I'm strongly
opinionated on this matter I save my
pontification for the very last chapter
where I give advice to educators and
school teachers and parents and the
light the rest is just simply a
celebration of the public's reaction to
this scientific controversy and I'll
leave you reading from oh there's one
book okay this is a letter from Madeline
Madeline Yost a dear scientist
and it's scientist tes T I thought that
was cute what do you call Pluto if it's
not a planet anymore if you make it a
planet again then the science books will
be right this is this letter came early
on if there are people who live there
then they won't exist anymore
why can't Pluto be a planet if it's
small that doesn't mean it has to be a
that doesn't mean doesn't have to be a
planet anymore some people like Pluto if
it doesn't exist then they don't have a
favorite planet please write back but
not in cursive because I can't read
cursive yet
all right in the back but I just came
from California I was in California for
like a week it was fun being there
reading what I'm about to read appendix
H California legislation relative to
Pluto's planetary status California
Assembly bill HR 36 introduced by
Assembly members keith richmond
republican district 38 and Joseph Kang
taeo milla Democrat is bipartisan
legislation and it's full of whereas
speak you know how legislation is where
whereas recent astronomical discoveries
including Pluto's all belong orbit and
the sighting of slightly larger Kuiper
belt objects have led astronomers to
question the planetary status of Pluto
fine and whereas the mean-spirited
International Astronomical Union decided
on August 24th this legislation is
posted that very same day which meant
they were working on this the
mean-spirited I a you decided on August
24th to disrespect Pluto by stripping it
of its planetary status and reclassified
as a lowly dwarf planet and Pluto
whereas Pluto was discovered in 1930 by
an American Clyde Tombaugh at the Lowell
Observatory Arizona and this discovery
resulted in millions of Californians
being taught that Pluto is the ninth
planet in the solar system
and whereas Pluto named after the Roman
god of the underworld and affectionately
sharing the name of California's most
famous animated dog has a special
connection to California history and
culture
culture whereas downgrading Pluto status
will cause psychological harm to some
California's who question their place in
the universe and worry about the
instability of universal constants okay
this goes on no okay no the bill did not
pass however however it was their tax
money at work nonetheless drafting such
legislation there's similar legislation
that came out in New Mexico long time
home of Clyde Tombaugh client I lived as
I lived out his last days in New Mexico
taught at institutions there New Mexico
beautiful skies many observatories are
there you know the VLA the Very Large
Array telescopes with the with the
dishes you see it in all the sci-fi
movies a bank of dishes that's it that's
in New Mexico they they have a
relationship with their astronomers
there they pass legislation that said no
matter what the astronomers in Prague
will tell you if you step across the
border into New Mexico Pluto as a planet
by law and so they took they they they
they felt strongly about this so the
only difference between the letters I
got from grownups and those from kids is
that the grown-ups spell better that's
all otherwise it's all the emotions just
spilling out on the page and this was
catharsis for me just to get it out of
my system out of my files to share it
with all of you for you to then perhaps
decide for yourself so thank you for
this time and attention
my favorite part is QA and we have a
microphone here which you're welcome to
come up to if you don't no one will hear
your question and there'll be this like
this dead spot in c-span TV and I'll
just be standing there and no one will
know what's going on but I'll know
what's going on I'll lead off until it
someone comes up to the mic oh you're
there okay bend the mic down there you
go and remind me again how old are you
eight that's right eight and a half yes
and what grade are you in
third third grade cool so what's your
question um well I just want to know
what did it feel like when you
discovered on that Pluto is not a planet
did you feel like excited or bored or
that's an excellent question here's what
I thought because I remember it I
remember the moment it happened by the
way Clyde Tombaugh was alive up through
the 1990s when we were discovering
Kuiper belt objects he was like named
defy I mean he was 24 in 1930 so you do
the math you add like 65 years so the
guy was low 90s in the 1990s still got
around if there was a conference
questioning Pluto status he'd be there
with his cane now you can't win an
argument with a 95 year old man who has
a cane okay
you just got to let that one go okay not
going to be around much longer just let
that let it just and I say that I mean
sound I'm not just make a poking fun I
monitored my email traffic and the and
the activity on Becton before there were
blogs there were chat rooms and I
monitored that and up until he died
there was like kind of a low level
discussion about whether Pluto should be
a planet practically the minute he died
it shot up and people felt a little more
brave about speaking of this now that he
wouldn't wouldn't be around to react to
it I expressed this point and someone
who was friends with the tombo family
friends with Clyde Tombaugh Widow said
to me came right up and said his widow
is still alive
what - how do you feel about that
disrespecting Clyde Tombaugh and I said
this is how you need to think about it
no Clyde Tombaugh did not discover the
ninth planet what does it mean to
discover the ninth of something you
already have a dove and it's the most
diminutive one at that is that something
to celebrate
maybe so however I've got something
better to celebrate let's celebrate the
fact that he discovered the first of a
new class of object in the solar system
that is a much greater a much greater
discovery than simply saying I
discovered the ninth one
oh yes littler than everything else it's
now is one of the biggest members of the
Kuiper belt
I think it's happier there
it's the [ __ ] the king of the car king
of the calmness instead of being like
the puny is planet so what what I
thought about at the time was that this
is the greatest thing we could do for
Pluto is given its a whole new class of
object in the solar system a new swath
of real estate to explore and that was
the point of view that I took and my
colleagues here took at the Museum and
we smiled not knowing how many people we
would piss off for that okay thank you
for your quick next question yes she
says she has two questions we give her
two questions it's really small okay
it's never the length of the question is
the length of the answer okay Pluto yeah
do you feel one day it would drop out of
sight and is there any other like summer
my planets you know clusters behind
Pluto that we haven't discovered yet
okay you all get that question so first
will will true Pluto ever drop out of
sight number one number two
are there other is there more to be
discovered in the outer solar system
that might let me add to your question
that might force us to further rethink
what's going on in the outer solar
system so I'll answer those first we
Pluto size has settled out in our
estimates of it but it is more than half
made of ice so in enough time it's
possible for all the ice to evaporate
and just get little air and little or
leaving laying bare it's rocky core then
it's something else it's likely that
many of the asteroids were once ice but
what's left over is what's what's there
once all the ice evaporated from
sunlight so but right now it's it's size
is stable but it doesn't get that close
to the Sun to generate huge tails but if
Pluto came to where earth is right now
heat from the Sun would evaporate that
ice and it would grow a tail that'd be
just embarrassing you couldn't be that
if you want to be a player you just
don't want that you can't be implanted
with the tail you know that so now as
far as the outer solar system goes if an
object is self-luminous
generates its own light
it's brightness will drop off as the
square of the distance so it's twice as
far away it's 1/4 as bright
three times as far away 1/9 is bright
all right I'm there we're together
if the object reflects sunlight and they
start moving it farther away it drops
off as one over the distance to the
fourth power
it gets dim very very quickly so they
could be large objects out there maybe
the size of Neptune
we don't know maybe at beyond the Kuiper
belt because they would have really
disturbed the Kuiper belt if it had it
large if this like way out there we just
don't know
we are telescopes aren't that powerful
to see them so we don't know but we're
pretty sure we got the Kuiper belt
figured out its extent in its range and
what the objects are doing so good
question
thanks yes in a bit of a more personal
question do you ever get depressed
knowing all the amazing creative ways
the universe can squish all the life on
Earth oh so the question is do I have
bouts of depression knowing firsthand
all the ways the universe wants to kill
us I'm a paraphrase but that's basically
what you're asking is that correct yeah
actually all those ways the universe can
kill us black holes becoming
spaghettified as you are drawn into a
black hole asteroid impacts gamma-ray
bursts they're all vastly more exciting
than getting hit by a bus okay so so I
mean my other book before this is called
death by black hole the title chapter of
a section titled the section was called
when the universe turns bad all the ways
the cosmos wants to kill us and it's a
fascinating subject
people happen to be really curious about
death
morbidly so I'm sitting on the airplane
minding my own business they look over
see I do astrophysics then out come the
questions
it's not Oh tell me about how big the
Sun is or know how tell me how beautiful
the night sky is no it's what when will
the that will the Sun explode will earth
tip on its axis will will the black hole
eat us will the big bang will the thing
will 2012 will we survive we go that's
all they care about that's all they care
about so um no I don't I don't get
depressed at all I find it rather
illuminating because I know I'm going to
die one day
let it be spectacular if I have that
choice so that's why okay before you go
let me just like your heat just 2012
let's understand something okay just for
the moment give me a minute just if you
google 2012 there's like thousands of
websites telling you the world is going
to end on the Solstice December 21st
2012 and you look well why something I
missed like what like I was just here
and then now the world is going to end
first of all nearly all cults oh their
success to Proclamation is that the
world will end in the lifetime of the
leader of that cult just check it out
they all have doomsday scenarios in the
lifetime of the leader of the cult that
makes you more compelled to join the
cult because the cult has ways to avoid
the death okay now that's the starters
so one of the statements I'll say is
that on that day December 21st the
center of the galaxy where there's a
black hole the Sun and the earth will
come in to exact alignment and there's
the worry that that extra gravity will
like knock earth off its axis you can
calculate what that extra gravity will
be from that calculation you know
nothing's going to happen to earth but
that doesn't convince people because
we're just the
pointy-headed intellectual scientists
why believe us about science so what do
we know so let's hold the calculation
aside for the moment it is true that the
center of the galaxy the Sun in the
earth will come into perfect alignment
on the Solstice
December 2012 that's true what they
don't tell you is that that perfect
alignment happens every December 21st
then left that out they forgot to tell
you one other thing I know you waiting
there in line but hang on got to get
this off my chest
remember I said Percival lowers looking
for Planet X Tom bough discovers Pluto
but it's not Planet X doesn't have
enough mass did you wonder whatever
happened to the planet x did I tell you
what did I tell you what happened to it
okay so people kept looking decade after
decade because Pluto was not Planet X
didn't have near the gravity to do what
it should have been doing to Neptune so
took to the 1990s for the clever
astronomer said let me look at the data
that's telling us that Neptune is
misbehaving
he found a telescope responsible for a
branch of the data for a section of the
data because you're getting data over
multiple telescopes over multiple
generations to determine this he looked
at the observing log of that telescope
and found out that right before certain
observations of Neptune were made the
guy like opened the gear box and then
put it back together again interfered
with the machinery of the data taking
device he said I wonder if that would
make a difference so he took those data
and removed them from the fit of the
equation just removed it and used all
the other telescopes and when he did
this Neptune landed smack dab on
Newton's laws
Planet X was a phantom all along
today all gravity is present and
accounted for in the solar system
all-important gravity there is no unseen
objects messing with anything else that
we can't account for which means on
those same 2012 websites where they talk
about Planet X they're talking about
some planet they do ruin some name they
give it this planet X exists in the mind
of the people who write those websites
and nowhere else the world will be here
before during and after 2012 I promise
next question was the criteria of
domination of your orbital zone the most
substantial criteria and demoting Pluto
as a planet yes was the criterion of
dominating your orbital zone the most
significant that's that separate that
there it is that's if you if you can't
control your neighborhood and by the way
initially when that was written it was
thought that you would just absorb all
the object you would vacuum them up with
with your gravity I'm using vacuum
loosely there obviously your gravity
would attract and integers clean it out
later it's learned that the distances
between many of these pieces may be so
large that you would never come close
enough for it to hit and be absorbed
into your physical body but it is
possible if you have a strong enough
gravity to deflect them out of the zone
your gravity can actually serve as like
a as a bat as a like a tennis racquet
something comes by you just knock it out
so you can clean your zone
gravitationally without ever having to
be smacked by what's orbiting there and
split will can't even do that
but like earth plows through two hundred
three hundred tons of meteors a day
earth would do that if earth did that
for a trillion years the mass of the
earth would grow by like one tenth of
one percent so basically we're in charge
of our zone all right two hundred
one sounds like a lot not to the earth
right if it landed on you that would be
bad but you you are littler than the
earth okay that's how that works
so yeah that's your question Thanks
before you worked here
did the museum believe that Pluto was a
planet because because on the chart of
the planets they had Neptune as the last
planet on which chart in the museum well
actually not in this museum the Hayden
Planetarium was built and open to the
public in 1935 after Pluto was
discovered and was widely believed to be
a planet so all accounting of the solar
system included Pluto in Chicago the
Adler Planetarium the first planetarium
in the United States Hayden was not the
first well we got very famous very
quickly among other things we launched
what became sky and telescope magazine
in our basement okay
it was the magazine called the sky
merged with another one called the
telescope so we had a lot of ways to
become well known at the time in Chicago
they built and design their facility and
opened in the year 1930 and there's a in
the foyer the entryway of their main
building there eight packs of the eight
planets in the solar system so they got
it wrong but now it's right again see
that's how that that's how that works
and then they were not the only ones who
had it wrong and then got it right
Gustav Holst's the composer composed the
planets in 1918 19-teens
I think he finished in 1921 before Pluto
was discovered there's a movement for
each planet no Pluto Pluto got
discovered they say hey you want to add
one in he'd started said no I'm not
interested then a host scholar scholars
like really study the work of the person
composed a pluto movement
to add to it did that about 10 years ago
but now what's he doing with what's
going on by the way on the periodic
table of elements
your rhenium is named after Uranus
Neptune am is named after Neptune
plutonium is named after pluto named on
false pretense by the way because we had
to run a planets there and there it was
got the name so we did not we always had
Pluto until 2000 Adler Planetarium never
had Pluto and then they did but now they
have to retract it so there you go a
quickie closer to home you've all been
on Fifth Avenue Rockefeller Center that
side of Rockefeller Center is Atlas okay
you've seen Atlas you've been there if
you look at the yoke across his back it
you know as an artist you try to
represent the universe somehow because
Atlas is holding up not the earth I
think well the world the known world so
the whole universe is on his back so how
do you represent that well there's this
sort of grid this spherical grid but the
yoke that supports that grid has the
symbols for the planets Mercury Venus
the hand-mirror earth with the longitude
and latitude line Mars with the circle
with the arrow on it it goes all the way
around and then like Neptune it goes
right on up to Neptune and there's no
Pluto Pluto wasn't discovered when that
sculpture was cast was designed and then
later cast so it's another one of these
places where Pluto was absent yes since
Pluto has another moon that's almost the
same size of it
wouldn't that make another category of
planets because it's almost like two
dwarf planets orbiting each other yes
if I were Pope of nomenclature my
nomenclature would have a category of
planet where you have double planets and
in the case of Pluto and Charon they are
so close to each other in size that the
point around which they orbit is in the
space between them for all other planets
and their moons you still always go
around your center of mass
you're never going around the center of
the host planet so it's over a little
bit it's always within the physical body
of the principal object so earth and the
moon our center of mass is about a
thousand miles beneath the earth's
surface but it's still within the earth
it's not out in space so I would like to
see a category of solar system object
that are that are double planets that
would be cool I'd like to see a category
of planets that are within the green
zone of a solar system where you might
find liquid water I'd like to see a
category planets that just simply has
rings a category planets that has
atmospheres a category planet that has
active volcanoes these are cuts through
the data where you can pick and choose
what to talk about in one breath and
that way understand the nature of the
solar system and at no time are you
sitting out memorizing by rote something
that's why we've got so angry because we
believe that there was something
mythical about the number nine and that
number gets changed and we find it as an
assault on who and what we are because
that defined the science in our heads
where had it been taught differently
from the beginning the number wouldn't
made any difference to us at all so I
agree thank you that question
hello
so looking outside of Pluto but back to
your hope to have the entire world look
at the sky if you have everybody look
through a telescope what would be your
cliff notes or your tricks for them to
know what they're looking at the
difference between planets stars
asteroids and comets at a glance we
actually thought this through
the 10 days I think it's 10 days in
April our days where the phase of the
moon is especially beautiful in a
telescope where planets are nicely
positioned in the twilight sky where
certain constellations are visible so
there's a combination of objects that
are nicely configured for
one-stop-shopping
of a telescope session that you might
have and that's not true for all times
of the year you'd have to wait some in
the evening and some in the early
morning hours so and if you own a
telescope
chances are own a good telescope chances
are you know what you're looking at you
know how to point it and some of the
most friendly people you will ever meet
there's a person on the street with the
telescope because they're in love with
the universe and as Carl Sagan once said
when you're in love you want to tell the
world and they're out there to just
share the love so they'll be there with
now you're wondering I suppose there's
like not an astronomer in a village and
the teacher gets a telescope and doesn't
know how to use it that's a problem I
mean we have to like work that one so I
think it's more a goal than a reality I
think it's a nice it's a noble goal a
noble goal the telescope enabled us to
understand our place in the universe
like no other instrument and so we're
going to work we're going to see so we
can make it happen yeah thank you thank
you for that
this looks like it's the last question
which puts great pressure on you for the
depth and breadth of what will come out
of your mouth well I'm not even try to
top all the other students questions
because they clearly are better studies
but as my favorite public science kind
of face of science right now personality
I wonder you thank you thank you thank
you no I think you you're just done such
a great deal inside I interject
something there hey I've done the
statistics on this 85% of my public
exposure on television and media is
driven by producers we're like the
universe flinches and they need a sound
byte they come to me I'm not twisting
their arms it's like 15 percent is where
there's a book that comes out and you
get sort of lever it into a talk show or
something but most of them are minding
my own business in my office and they
call which for me is a statement a
testament to the public's appetite for
the cosmos that it happens without me
trying to force it on them so however
when you see me it's really the
compliment to what the demand that the
public has for this material so go on
exactly I think the demand is great I
agree and with your prospects with NASA
and all that I think that you are the
face of well but but I mean basically
with me the rumor
the rumor but basically you are the face
of science rumor or a lot of people you
know this rumor it's a it's one of these
it's true that it's a rumor that doesn't
mean that the rumor is true
see that's what did it I've been rumored
to be on a list to be head of NASA and
yeah but but my feeling is on that not
that you asked I will tell you my
feelings on that is we all love net we
all care for NASA we all want it to
succeed question is where are my efforts
best invoked in the service of NASA is
it as head of this ship called NASA or
is it if I'm not in NASA then I can
still do the TV and I still write books
and they still write what they publish
my op eds I have access to the public
who then has sentiment in favor of NASA
that can influence lawmakers so I think
in the end I mean I'm not bucking for
the job the people who would love that
job I'm not among them but I see my name
in the list so I'm flattered and honored
but it's not like I'm after it so I keep
interrupting so your question is sorry
yeah I mean it my question is extremely
important that's why we need to get to
it okay I'm just kidding
but um no because you're now the public
face of science I just wonder what you
consider is your favorite based purely
on charisma or personality your favorite
past public face of science you be it
Sagan or Burke or you know arthur c--
clark and who nah
who else okay well that's it that's an
easy question I thought you had a heart
but why and why show all work yes okay
yes teacher
okay yes mrs. McGillicuddy I'll show all
work so thank you for that question
there's no doubt at all I'll end on this
answer because it is the right place to
end there is no doubt at all that I so
much of what I do professionally in the
eyes of the public exists in this in
this swath cut in a in a in a in a rough
and field by Carl Sagan there's no
question about it practically every
thought I've ever had about reaching the
public he's had before me and written on
it and done it and so I'm here just
simply time-shifted from him but in fact
is very little that I'm doing that is
that is sort of unique in the history of
people's attempts to reach the public
it's just not yes they're different the
the media is different right there's Jon
Stewart rather than Johnny Carson you
know there are things there's certain
different channels yes but the the
activity the motivation for the activity
is identical it's identical now I I
think Carl Sagan did it better than
anyone before him or even since he's he
part of it was yet yet charisma he's
brilliant what a main difference between
us is that he actually had a scientific
agenda okay he wanted to create
basically single-handedly created a
brand new field of science called
astrobiology and he did this with his I
mean he put it into his work in his
writing and I don't I don't have a gen I
don't I'm really just a servant of the
community's collective interest so when
you read my writings any one of us could
have written that it's not just my view
it's really a consensus view so that's
one I think one difference but what I
want to leave you with is you ask me why
why would I cite him when I was in high
school kid in high school I went to the
Bronx High School of Science Bronx in
the house yes we had Bronx in the house
a storied school a school that seven
Nobel Prize winners came out of that
school all in physics by the way my most
formative years of my life were spent in
that school I applied to colleges Carl
Sagan's professor at Cornell I applied
to Cornell I'm accepted at Cornell
within two weeks I get a letter from
Carl Sagan I'm 17 years old
I said Carl Sagan this is just a car
from Johnny Carson The Tonight Show host
at the time Johnny Carson the this be
Hannah I opened it up it said the
admissions office forwarded me your
application it was clear to that
that you have a deep interest in the
universe which I've had since I was nine
years old since my first visit to the
Hayden Planetarium so they said if
you're still wondering what school you
might attend if you'd like to visit
Cornell I'd be happy to host your visit
just let me know and I'll show you the
labs so I can't even I you know I it's
like I can't what mom you know what did
he tell with that letter so so we
arranged a trip take a bus up to Ithaca
it's in the winter cuz that's when they
tell you when you're accepted is in the
winter it's cold okay he meets me out
front of the lab invites me in I'm in
his office he reaches back and pulls out
I just throws the coolest things in
reach back one of his books right cuz
reaches back signs it to me I still have
this book Who am I I'm just some kid Oh
Who am I to him I'm nothing to him
not really but then I found out maybe I
was everything to him
we spent the day walking around he
showed me the lab we were done drove me
back to the bus station it starts to
snow he says I worry the bus might not
get through here's my home phone if the
bus doesn't get through call spend the
night at our home to this day when
students email me call me send me a
notice I stop everything I get I might
have email from like the head of the
museum my Provost that goes on the side
because I swore after that moment that
if I were ever as important or as famous
as Carl Sagan that I sure as hell would
be treating students in the next
generation the way he treated me
that's why so thank you all thank you
thank you
thank you
for more information on Neil deGrasse
Tyson author of the Pluto files visit
Hayden Planetarium org